can you name one thing in this photo
just one thing
[Music]
okay
can you name one thing in this photo
just one thing
and you know even bring it closer look
at it right now he can't see you just
bring the whole thing over Mellie oh my
gosh it stresses me out can you name one
thing in this photo if you're listening
to the audio version of this there is a
photo can I identify what something is
name one thing in this photo
okay first of all I thought you were
asking me a question that it would be
impossible not to ask
I don't know what I'm looking at here
I'm just looking at exactly man an
amorphous blob of
stuff of clutter of stuff of excess of
hoarding of uselessness of super
abundance of over abundance we own too
much stuff and this photo is the perfect
representation when we have heaped so
many possessions into our lives
what happens
we can't even name the things that we
own if you're just listen to the audio
version there's a picture here full of
stuff I'm going to put a link to this
specific picture in the show notes so
you can see it for yourself if you're
not watching the video version of the
podcast right now but my goodness if you
look at this picture
I can't name a single thing in there
maybe there's some jewelry I'm not
really sure although I would just call
it trash yeah and look for our listeners
what I'm looking at right now I mean you
would think that you can identify one
thing right like oh there's a bed or or
a pillow or a stuffed animal but there's
something which could be possibly
construed as a stuffed animal-like thing
but it's not quite clear I can't even
say blanket bed
desk I mean stuff has to sit on
something I can't even say floor I don't
even know what the stuff is on yeah we'd
really describe it if we could folks
like this is what the world looks like
without my glasses on that's how how
Indescribable it is this is what the
world looks like when you say yes to
everything oh
I am going to accept that into my life
it's a bunch of micro yeses I'll buy
this I'll take the free good I'll take
the tchotchke I need this I'll hold on
to this I can't let go of that because
just in case uh hold on to this one
because someday I know that it could
potentially be useful and then what
happens is it all becomes useless it
becomes an amorphous blob of clutter of
trash of excess of
anxiety I look at this picture and I
think oh how stressed out would I be if
this was my home or my living room or my
bathroom or my closet or if this is my
garage or my attic I would want to do
something about this immediately because
of the internal clutter that it would
cause in my everyday well-being
crazy
I challenge an optical illusion or do
you know who originated this or what it
actually is well I don't want to ruin it
so in the comments let us know what you
think huh is in this photo I'm really
curious if you can make out just one
thing from this photo
I hope you enjoyed that highlight from
the minimalist private podcast if you
did and you'd like to dive deep into
full episodes of the private podcast
head on over to patreon just click the
link down in the description the private
podcast keeps our YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck but if you're not
ready for that just yet head on over to
this video on our YouTube channel
thank you